1 i 2000 17 uhr 1 oder murat wie das
mysteriöse objekt aus dem interstellaren
raum mittlerweile als der brocken hat
die form eines schwerst kenneth also
einem raumschiff und der gilt als
wirkliche sensation jetzt hat ein
forschungsteam aus irland neue
erkenntnisse zu seiner zusammensetzung
ob das rätsel um seine identität jetzt
endgültig gelöst ist und inwieweit
aliens in der neuen theorie eine rolle
spielen jetzt in klink zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen vor ein paar
tagen haben wir erst berichtet ein
forschungsteam der initiative
breakthrough listen hatte eine große
aktion gestartet mit dem radioteleskop
wollten sie den mysteriösen brocken über
mehrere frequenzen abhören wo kommt
humor her woraus besteht der sendete er
signale außerirdischer intelligenz aber
es blieb alles ruhig bislang zumindest
doch das ändert nichts daran humor
bleibt mehr als mysteriös und
forschungsteams weltweit suchen
fieberhaft nach neuen erkenntnissen oder
zumindest hinweisen um seine identität
zu klären denn es sind mehr fragen offen
als beantwortet fest steht nur es
handelt sich um das erste interstellare
objekt das nicht aus unserem
sonnensystem stammt und dessen durchflug
wir beobachten konnten schätzungen
zufolge soll das etwa ein mal im jahr
passieren dass also ein interstellarer
besucher unser sonnensystem durchquert
um nur moore ist der erste der eindeutig
identifiziert werden konnte wegen ihm
gibt es jetzt eine neue kategorie der
internationalen astronomischen union ii
für interstellar das seltsame der
brocken besteht wohl nicht aus gas und
also wie wir sonst von kometen aus
unserem sonnensystem kennt denn sonst
hätte er ja verdampfen müssen als er am
19 september 2017 an unserer sonne
vorbei geflogen ist um moore sei ein
einfacher gesteinsbrocken sowie ein ass
en ihn sagt jetzt ein forschungsteam von
der queen's university in belfast
entstanden sei er aus den grundbaustein
aller planeten kleine partikel
kondensieren im weltall und heften sich
aneinander erst zu winzigen klümpchen
dann zu großen brocken in der
fachsprache bleibt nähte sie male
genannt also quasi so etwas wie das
rohmaterial für planeten
humor habe allerdings eine isolierende
schutzschicht bestehend aus kohlenstoff
verbindung diese hat nach angaben des
forschungsteams eine gewisse ähnlichkeit
mit den objekten die sich am rand
unseres sonnensystems befinden und eben
auch mit kohle stoff reiche mais bedeckt
sind und das ist echt eine überraschung
sagt auch eine der beteiligten
forscherinnen mit kälbern ist es ist
faszinierend dass das erste entdeckte
interstellare objekt so sehr wie eine
winzige welt aus unserem eigenen heimat
system anmutet entstanden sei die küste
von humor bei seiner reise durch den
weltraum und dem beschuss von kosmischer
strahlung genau diese kruste schütze dem
brocken jetzt gegen die hitze sonne und
was wir sonst noch über ihn wissen humor
ist rund zehnmal so lang wie er breit
ist das teleskop an stars auf hawaii
hatte ihm jahr am 19 oktober entdeckt er
kam aus der richtung des sterns wega im
sternbild leier im wahrsten sinne des
wortes von oben senkrecht zu den
umlaufbahnen zwischen sonne und merkur
bahn zudem verhält er sich wirklich
ziemlich spooky es rot wird mal heller
mal dunkler messungen haben ergeben dass
er seine helligkeit um den faktor 10
verändert zudem rotiert der wohl das ist
das ergebnis dieser helligkeits
veränderungen wohl alle 73 stunden um
seine eigene achse zurück zu den
neuesten erkenntnissen demnach ist humor
also ein natürliches objekt und das
bremst natürlich die hoffnung darauf
gleich in diesem zusammenhang doch noch
hinweise auf außerirdisches leben zu
entdecken doch die forschungsteams geben
nicht auf denn die bereits gesammelten
daten von humor sind noch lange nicht
alle analysiert also doch ein raumschiff
sowie auch ihr es schon spekuliert hatte
die chance stehen ehrlich gesagt
schlecht aber wir bleiben dran wenn er
kein video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollte hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergessen nicht den
genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr
auch immer über neue videos informiert
hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken eine sensation
interstellare objekt rast durchs
sonnensystem mit allen weiteren infos
humor also ansonsten bisher bleibt kann